segundo intento fallido la ciudad de
mariupol buscaba evacuar a los civiles
después de otra tentativa fallida el
sábado las fuerzas de vladimir putin han
estado bombardeando esta ciudad
estratégica en el sur de ucrania tomar
el control de mariupol uniría las zonas
separatistas del donbass con crimea
anexionada por rusia hace 8 años los
4500 habitantes de la ciudad llevan
varios días sin agua electricidad ni
combustible pese a que temen a los
ataques huir podría ser arriesgado aquí
un convoy de periodistas intentaba
abandonar la zona pero fue rodeado por
soldados que les apuntaban con sus armas
para permitir la salida de civiles de la
ciudad se había acordado un alto al
fuego el sábado tanto los rusos como los
ucranianos se acusaron mutuamente de no
haberlo respetado nos mintieron nos
dijeron que iba a haber un actual fuego
durante el día desde las 9 hasta las 6
de la tarde nos pidieron que nos
preparáramos nos preparamos organizamos
los autobuses pero a pesar de que
conocen los problemas que enfrenta la
ciudad el ejército ruso bombardeo
nuestro convoy de autobuses destruyeron
la mitad
una acusación negada por rusia
nos han informado que las autoridades de
mariupol se niegan a dar a los
habitantes la posibilidad de salir por
el corredor humanitario que puso en
marcha el ejército ruso y
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski ha buscado el apoyo de la otan
pero la organización se ha negado a
cerrar el espacio aéreo del país la
alianza aseguró que no quiere una
confrontación directa con rusia mientras
que putin sentenció que hacerlo sería
tomado como una participación en el
conflicto